ces soldats ukrainien patrouille dans la
ville dévastée dire pin l'une des
nombreuses communes au nord de kiev
reprises aux mains des troupes russes
des soldats constate également le départ
de certaines unités russes de tchernihiv
mais pas de retrait massif comme annoncé
par moscou dans cette zone fortement
bombardée dans la nuit de mardi selon le
pentagone l'armée russe commence aussi à
se retirer de tchernobyl et d'un
aéroport près de la capitale ukrainienne
washington l'heure est au
repositionnement
probablement aux alentours de 20% des
troupes russes déployées contre kiev
commencent à se repositionner certes
elle se repositionne en deux lots russie
mais à l'est la situation est toujours
inquiétante dans le donbass région
désormais au coeur de la stratégie de
moscou les autorités ukrainiennes accusé
la russie d'avoir tiré mercredi des obus
au phosphore sur le village de marine
cas des armes interdites contre les
civils selon la convention de genève le
président ukrainien reste sceptique sur
la réduction de l'activité militaire des
russes dans le pays
nous voyons l'accumulation nos troupes
russes pour de nouvelles frappes de
l'otan des races
nous nous préparons à cela nous croyons
personne nous ne croyons pas aux belles
phrases
il ya une situation réelle sur le champ
de bataille c'est cela qui compte nous
ne céderons rien à marioupol dans le sud
du dombass la crise humanitaire continue
à s'aggraver les civils sont toujours
prises au piège sans eau potable ni
électricité
le ministère russe de la défense a
annoncé un cessez-le-feu à partir de 10h
heure locale pour permettre l'évacuation
des habitants vers la ville de sa peau
ridge et des opérations humanitaires qui
ont jusque-là toujours échoué